if we discover aliens we'll probably see
them because of their farts
the first signature of extraterrestrial
life is likely to be
unnatural compositions of gases in the
atmosphere of a distant exoplanet
think of the earth the atmosphere is
full of oxygen
and this is only true because it keeps
on being replenished by plant and
microbial life
if life disappeared on earth so would
the oxygen
so if we see a distant planet with an
atmosphere where the proportions of
gases are
inexplicable by the laws of chemistry
alone like lots of oxygen or a mix of
carbon dioxide and methane
but with little carbon monoxide this
would be a biosignature a strong
indicator that
at least microbial life exists there to
confirm any large creatures exist we'll
just have to visit
but how do we know what chemicals the
atmosphere of a distant planet contains
the answer is atomic spectroscopy if we
see a planet transiting in front of its
star
some of that starlight is absorbed in a
very specific pattern called an atomic
absorption
spectrum each element has a specific
pattern
like a barcode so through careful
analysis of the light
it can tell us which gases are in the
atmosphere and their proportions
we already used this technique for other
space objects like stars and nebulae
measuring properties like temperature
density ionization and relative velocity
think about how cool this is we can look
into deep space and get
so much information just from the light
it's like a gift that the laws of
physics have given us
and we've used it most of our knowledge
of the universe comes from this
technique
i've previously mentioned atomic spectre
in my map of quantum physics video
because this subject is so cool i made
this video to dig deeper
there are two kinds of atomic spectra
absorption spectra which is where the
light source is behind a gas and the gas
absorbs and scatters certain wavelengths
of light
leaving dark lines in the spectrum of
the star
the opposite is a mission spectra which
is the same process but seen from a
different
angle now you're only looking at the
re-radiated light of this nebula
here it's worth noting a few things a
hot gas on its own emits light as an
emission
spectrum here i'm drawing the intensity
of the light on the vertical axis
a hot solid emits a spectrum at all
wavelengths called a thermal spectrum
and so you can't tell what material the
object's made from only how hot it is
and a star emits a combination of a
thermal spectrum with an absorption
spectrum superimposed on top
which comes from their upper layers so
in atomic spectra why do we get these
very specific
lines to answer that we need to delve
into
the world of quantum mechanics
light is absorbed and emitted by the
electrons in atoms
and these electrons can only exist in
certain energy states which
plotted for hydrogen look like this
the reason for these discrete energy
states is that in quantum mechanics
electrons are described by a wave called
a wave function
and this wave can only vibrate at
certain frequencies in the constraint of
the atom
this is just like a guitar string which
only vibrates at certain frequencies in
the constraint of being tied
to the guitar these waves are standing
waves and each higher energy wave
includes an extra half wavelength and
oscillates at a higher frequency
i've simplified the drawings to one
dimension but in reality these are
actually three dimensional waves because
the electron cloud is three-dimensional
as you go up there's an infinite number
of energy levels because you can keep on
adding one more half wavelength to the
electron wave but
the difference in energies between these
levels gets smaller and smaller
because the difference between the waves
gets smaller and smaller
the biggest difference in energy is
between the ground state and the first
excited state
when light shines on atoms if it
contains light with the same energy as
one of the distances between the energy
levels of the electron
it can absorb that light and the
electron jumps to a higher energy
then later it will jump back down to a
lower energy emitting the light
in a random direction this is why we see
dark bands in the absorption spectrum
because
the electrons are absorbing the light
and then scattering it mostly in a
different direction to the original
light
so it's taking out those frequencies of
the light and
an emission spectrum is just made of
that scattered light
light is made of particles called
photons and the energy of a photon is
based solely on its frequency which you
can see from this equation
e equals hf where h is a constant called
planck's constant
also the frequency and wavelength are
related to each other inversely by this
equation
where c is the speed of light in a
vacuum
here we have part of the emission
spectrum from hydrogen
you'll notice that there are three
groups of spectral lines
now there's a good reason for this the
first group is called the lyman group
it is made from all the decays from high
energy states down to the ground state
the other groups come from energy decays
from above down to higher energy levels
in a similar way
that's why the lines are grouped like
this
note that this is not to scale in
reality these lines are far more spread
out in the wavelength scale and there
are even more series at longer
wavelengths
you should also note that i've only been
using hydrogen as examples because it's
only got one proton and one electron so
it's got a relatively simple spectrum
but the spectra of other elements are
more complex and
a real observation of many many
different gases overlapping is
incredibly complex
now you know all the basics of atomic
spectra but it's also worth knowing
about
fine structure and hyperfine structure
these are where if you look at a
spectral line really closely you'll see
that they're often made of two
or more spectral lines that are
incredibly close together
the atomic spectra we've talked about so
far are an idealized model but when you
add in the spin of the electron and also
relativistic effects you get the fine
structure splitting of energy levels
and beyond that the hyperfine structure
is seen as small shifts and splittings
of these energy levels caused by
interaction between the electrons and
the nucleus through their mutual
magnetic or electric fields
as well as other effects
now it's important to note that what
i've described so far isn't the only way
that light interacts with matter
there are a few other ways that you
should know about the most common is
scattering which happens when electrons
are free to wiggle about when light
shines on them called rally scattering
you don't need the rules of quantum
physics to describe this
it's a classical effect of light being a
vibrating electromagnetic wave which
interacts with the electric
charge of the electrons causing them to
wobble and they then become
an oscillating source of more
electromagnetic waves which radiate
out in all directions this scattering is
what causes the blue colour of the sky
and the red colour of sunsets
it's also why metals are very reflective
because they have lots of free electrons
that move around very easily
we've also got raman scattering where
light shines on molecules and can
vibrate the molecules in different modes
and it's got its own spectroscopy called
raman spectroscopy
and there's also brilliant scattering
where light can lose or gain energy when
interacting with vibrational waves in
the atomic lattices of solids
finally let's look at the applications
of atomic spectra
i've already mentioned the array of uses
in astrophysics
the other main use is to see what
elements and compounds something is made
of
this is used in chemistry labs to see
what a sample is made of
or using the hyperfine structure to
delve into the nucleus with
nuclear magnetic resonance and other
techniques
lasers come from controlling the
emissions from specific energy levels
we can also harness the accuracy and
repeatability of the energy levels
for example atomic clocks all need a
standard oscillator to keep the same
time
and so use the light from a specific
hyperfine transition of the cesium-133
atom which is also how the si units of
distance the meter
and time the second are defined and so
this also sets the definition of the
speed of light
so that's my introduction to atomic
spectra very cool stuff
i'll be looking at other topics from the
map of quantum physics in the future so
consider subscribing if you want to
catch those this post is still available
on dftba as well
and if you value my videos and would
like to help support me make them
i have a patreon page where you can
donate anything from a dollar per video
to get access to some behind the scenes
material lately i've been posting work
in progress scripts and images
and also video previews before they go
live on youtube
but no obligation i appreciate you
watching and i'll see you in the next
video